let's go next to our caller from the 775
area code 775 what's your name were you
calling from uh hey David my name is
Emmanuel
I'm calling from Reno Nevada hey how are
you fine my family uh huge fans we
watched you pretty much every day so I
appreciate you uh giving us a chance to
call in my pleasure
my question is in here Nevada if you get
committed if you commit a crime and
you're charged with a crime if they find
that you're addicted to some type of
drugs they have a program called drug
court where if you complete the program
you know you pretty much those charges
get dropped do you think that if Trump
does eventually get charged they will
bring up his obvious you know narcotic
or upper edition no listen I I love the
question and I actually I'm guessing
that this only applies to certain crimes
right like if you murder someone and you
say I'm on drugs they don't say hey you
can do a drug program and we won't
indict you for murder right it doesn't
work that way correct okay yeah it's
only there's more that's probably the
only crime that it wouldn't apply to but
pretty much anything else in our in our
state as well as there's other states
that have similar programs you're saying
that in Nevada if you're accused of
violently raping someone but you say I
was high at the time they will say go to
a drug program and you don't get
indicted that doesn't sound right it
does sound kind of crazy but
unfortunately that's pretty much how it
is you can run someone over if you say I
was you know on addicted to drugs it's
okay no big the car accident the
vehicular manslaughter that's a bigger
issue and there's a lot of research
about how if you wanted to murder
someone one of the most it's one of the
safest ways to do it is to run them over
in what looks like a car accident that
that's a very specific one but in any
case I don't know exactly what crimes
fall under this or don't doesn't really
matter your question about if Trump gets
indicted after being out of office could
he cite a drug problem as the reason why
he did it
Trump is not going to get into that once
he gets out of office and I keep this is
something I keep coming back to the 25th
amendment won't remove
from the molar probe was never going to
remove Trump impeachment is not going to
remove Trump there's one opportunity to
remove Trump earlier than he otherwise
might be removed which is to vote him
out in November rather than give him a
second term I think thinking about
anything other than getting out the vote
in November is is maybe theoretically
interesting but I don't know that we
would want to put too much time into it
because it's not going to happen
right well how about this this is my
last question dude I know you got a lot
more people how come B why do you think
sometimes the media hasn't really
connected the dots between Russia's
interest in Ukraine and why Trump has
such a you know a foothold you know on
what he's trying to do in Ukraine isn't
it obvious that whatever he's doing in
Ukraine is its most likely benefiting
Russia he's probably working for Russia
well you have to accept some premises
that a lot of people right now reject in
order that analysis makes sense if you
accept some of the premises about the
relationship between Russia and the
United States and to counter what you're
saying that nobody's mentioning it I
have seen some mentions of that but very
quickly they're kind of shouted down as
you know hoaxers Russia conspiracy
theorists or whatever so it often
doesn't really get the full conversation
it might deserve sad well that makes
sense you pretty much answered
everything I had in mind David and uh
again we appreciate your you're working
all right Thank You Manuel say hi to
everybody over there appreciate the
support of your family and I hope to
hear from you again